the world of One Piece has finally come
into live action in the form of a
Netflix television show but who's behind
bringing this worldwide phenomenon to
life here's what you need to know before
you watch Netflix's one piece
news of an American-made live-action
one-piece TV show dates back to July
2017. this was when producer and
self-professed one-piece fan Marty
adelstein announced that his company
tomorrow Studios had secured a
partnership with shueisha and author
oichiro Oda to adapt one piece into a
live-action TV series Oda later revealed
that he actually entered discussions
about the live-action English language
version of one piece a year earlier in
2016. so it's been a long time coming at
this point so what do you say
are you with me
Netflix officially picked up the series
in 2020 and ordered a 10 episode first
season that was later reduced to Ace
though production faced lengthy delays
during the covid-19 pandemic production
picked up again during 2021 and the
series began filming in early 2022
though no details on a release date were
given at that point fans speculated that
the show would drop at some point in
2023 and they were correct as revealed
at Netflix's taduma event in Brazil we
now know that all eight episodes of One
Piece season 1 will premiere on August
31st 2023
one piece takes place in a fictional
world not too dissimilar to our own
though much of the planet's surface is
covered by water the only continent is
called the Red Line a narrow strip of
land that goes all the way around the
globe also circling the globe is the
grand line a stretch of ocean that's
known for its rapidly changing weather
and dangerous sea life when they cross
these two lines split a huge body of
water known as the blue sea into four
quadrants the East blue the West Blue
the North Blue and the South Blue there
are many many islands in the blue sea
some of them safer than others this is a
world full of pirates after all the
story follows a straw hat pirate named
after the hat worn by the optimistic
Captain Monkey D Luffy it's Luffy's
dream to find the legendary treasure
known as the one piece which was hidden
by the famed pirate Goldie Roger before
his execution at the hands of the world
government whoever finds it will be
proclaimed the new pirate king and Luffy
won't stop until that title is his he
knows he can't do this alone however so
he sets about putting a crew together
and making a name from elf this is all
covered in the East blue Saga in which
going by the promotional material and
casting news is what the first season of
Netflix's one piece will be based on
the lead role of Monkey D Luffy is being
played by a young actor named inyaki
Godoy building on a filmography that
thus far consists predominantly of
projects made in his home country of
Mexico in an interview with decider go
DOI revealed that he started reading the
manga and watching the anime after
winning his one-piece role mainly so he
could get a grasp on Luffy's bizarre
physicality after eating a devil fruit
his body is the properties of rubber he
said how can I translate this rubber man
into live action in those cases I really
use the anime and manga for reference so
I literally tried to replicate the way
this guy fights he continued in detail
when he throws a point and he takes it
back he puts his hand on his bicep or
his shoulder so if he does that I should
do that too right and when he's about to
throw a punch sometimes he lifts up his
leg I just try to look for those little
details in the original product rounding
out Luffy's straw out Pirates crew I'm a
kenyu the son of martial arts movie
Legend Sunny Chiba as the legendary
swordsman Zorro Emily Rudd who played
Clara in Amazon's Hunters appears as the
enigmatic thief and Navigator Nami
that's Skyler who you might remember as
Walton TNT's the Lazarus Project plays a
womanizing chef Sanji rounding out the
straw hats as Jacob Romero Gibson who
played AJ delaji in owns Greenleaf as a
skilled Marksman usop supporting
additions to the cast include Peter
gadio as Luffy's Idol redhead Shanks
McKinley belt to the third as a
villainous fisherman along Ilya is a
Raley's Paulino that's ruthless pirate
alvida and Jeff Ward is a clown dressing
Captain buggy we'll also see Stephen
Ward as a fearsome sword fighter mihawk
chioma you media as nami's adoptive
older sister nojiko and Morgan Davies as
Cabin Boy and future Navy Captain Kobe
it has been confirmed that the first two
episodes of One Piece season 1 are
directed by Mark jobs who has some
history with shows about Pirates having
helmed a season 4 episode of Black Sails
the Stars Series has run for Four
Seasons between 2014 and 2017 is a
pre-quarter Treasure Island and is about
Pirates seeking riches while evading the
British government the themes are very
similar though there's no superpowers in
Black Sails but that's not to say that
jobs doesn't have experience in that
area jobs is perhaps best known for his
work on Netflix's hit Daredevil series
most notably helming the season 3 opener
Resurrection he also directed a couple
of episodes of Luke Cage meaning he has
a shared history with one Pete's
co-showrunner Matt Owens Owens was a
staff writer and executive story editor
on the Marvel show jobs is also known
for directing episodes of The Witcher
and Jupiter's Legacy both Netflix shows
so he's clearly trusted by the higher
rubs of the streamer
Marty adelstein whose company tomorrow
Studios helped get the live-action one
piece series off the ground as an
executive producer on the show but fans
will no doubt be more excited to learn
that one piece Creator atrio Oda is also
producing when odar was first approached
about adapting his long-running manga
into a live-action English language
series back in 2016. he had some doubts
even after agreeing to the project he
had some major reservations as there was
some difficulties to begin with in a
lengthy Instagram post odar wrote we
obviously come from very different
cultures so when it comes to
entertainment we have different codes
skill sets and aims sometimes it could
be frustrating for both sides it felt
like we're all trying to get to the same
place so how come we're not in the same
wavelength there was even a time when I
thought it's a foreign production even
possible luckily they were all able to
get onto the same page taking the series
in the direction that odar was happy
with the Creator revealed that he had
and still has a final say when it comes
to what goes into the Netflix show he
wrote they've prom I must say won't
launch until I'm satisfied they're
burning with passion and I've reminded
everyone involved that this should be
fun
in what was perhaps the most exciting
announcement at Anime Expo 2023 it was
confirmed that the voice cast from the
long-running one-piece anime series will
be playing their respective characters
in the Japanese sub of Netflix's
live-action show an eclipse shared at
the convention inyaki Godoy revealed
that he recently took a trip to Tokyo to
meet the original voice of Luffy my Yumi
Tanaka Tanaka has been playing Luffy
since 1999. so as a fan godo was
understandably very excited to meet her
Luffy and you inspire me to be the best
version of myself that I can be I'm just
so honored to meet you it seems like
Tanaka was proud of the new Luffy actor
too since he presented him with a straw
hat as a gift telling him I leave this
hat with the air bring it to me someday
when you become a great pirate
Sharon is Matt Owens and Steven maieda
wrote the first and last episode of
Netflix's one piece entitled romance
Dawn and worse in the East my editor is
perhaps best known as one of the
producers of lost but he has plenty of
other noteworthy credits to his name
including lie to me and Helix he also
wrote more than 40 episodes of The
X-Files between 2000 and 2002. Mata wins
with a staff writer and executive story
editor on Daredevil but that's not the
only Marvel show he's been involved in
it was also a writer on Luke Cage Agents
of Shield and the Defenders the other
writers involved in one piece have
worked on shows like the animated Harley
Quinn series Supergirl and Umbrella
Academy so it seemed like the humorous
super powered antics of the Manga and
Anime will be in good hands
when Netflix releases second trailer the
streamer shared some words from One
Piece Creator a chiro Oda in a note that
was posted to Twitter odas said that he
fully expected fans of the source
material to highlight the differences
between the manga and the live-action
show after the launch I'm sure I hear
about some people pointing out how this
character is missing or that scene is
omitted or this bit is different from
the manga but I'm sure they'll come from
a place of love so I intend to enjoy
even those comments as odar predicted
most of the early comments were
good-natured with fans on the whole
accepting that some changes need to be
made when it comes to creating something
in real life one Reddit user wrote I
definitely see some changes to the plot
along's Crews seemed to show up at the
baratier buggies Cruise teams of a
natural circus going on plus it seems
like the going merry encounters GARP
ship at one point everything still looks
really good though you'll never please
everyone when it comes to adopting a
beloved manga series but the live action
one piece seems off plenty of support
from the fandom when it comes to making
tweaks of course having odor on board
certainly helps
[Music]